I want to do something different for our
third show we're going to get away from
atheism and religion today believe it or
not and we're going to focus on another
passion of mine politics real quick
though I should thank all of you that
listened to last week's direct message
and actually took it into action you
guys are calling out the [ __ ]
artists on every social media platform
like I've never seen before as I said
last week when you guys are engaged we
can focus on other things and not just
have the same conversation over and over
I've really only been intimately
involved in this conversation for a
couple weeks fighting the lies is not
only exhausting but it has also affected
a couple of my friendships I really do
think that part of the plan by these
people is to tire out the good guys into
giving up your part in this debate is
beyond crucial but enough of that let's
talk politics I was at the GOP debate at
the Reagan Library last week I've never
been to one of these things before and I
really had no idea what to expect behind
the scenes we had a booth in the spin
room right alongside CNN MSNBC and Fox
News the fact they call it the spin room
really tells you all you need to know
about this thing this is where campaign
people and candidates go to spin their
message I went to the truth room next
door but nobody was there weird huh we
were able to snag surrogates from pretty
much every candidate except for Carly
Fiorina and Donald Trump because neither
of them sent any reps to the floor I
even got to ask John Kasich a question
about gay marriage and Scott Walker a
question about money in politics come to
think of it maybe that's what caused him
to drop out of the race earlier this
week what I realized by being on the
inside of all this is that there are
some unspoken rules to how the game is
played I talked to Mike Huckabee's
campaign manager about gay marriage and
she basically just danced around it had
I pushed her to the breaking point I
probably would have never gotten access
to her again and then word would have
traveled fast that I'm someone that they
shouldn't talk to so with that in mind I
tried my best to navigate all the
interviews with some basic questions and
then some deeper probing I asked pretty
much everyone about campaign finance and
I really pushed on social issues there
was a big learning experience and we'll
figure out how to engage with the
candidates and the representatives in an
even more incisive way beyond the spin
and the sound bites hopefully as the
show gets bigger we'll get two more of
the debates candidates will eventually
realize that I'm going to be tough but
honest whether we agree or not we're
plotting out our plan to go to the first
democratic debate in October
right now so stay tuned for that so for
today's show we're going to jump back
into the political waters I've got two
comics I like and respect Jimmy Dore and
Felicia Michaels I agree with them on
some issues and a disagree with them on
some others what I know more than
anything else though is that comedians
have a way of holding themselves to a
high standard of truth sure we'll get
things wrong but the good ones have a
fearless desire to say controversial
things and let the chips fall where they
may as Billy Wilder said if you're going
to tell people the truth be funny or
they will kill you I guess you could say
the comedians are guardians of peace and
justice in the galaxy just like the Jedi
well except comedians usually smoke a
lot more weed